[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
ارهابيه متهمه بالضلوعي في مقتل الدلابيح
ومقتلوا ثلاثه من عناصر الامن في العمليه
تطالبه بتنحي رئاسه تويتر وترقب لقراره
المحتجون في ايران يبداون اضرابات ثلاث
ايام وسلطات تخترق هواتف المعتقلين
وبوتن في ضيافه حليفه البيلاروسيه لاول
مره منذ ثلاث سنوات تزامنا مع مناورات
عسكريه بين البلدين
اذا مشاهدينا البدايه من الاردن اكد الامن
العام الاردني ان قوه امنيه خاصه نفذت
مداهمه لخليه ارهابيه في منطقه الحسينيه
في معان هذه المداهمه اعتمدت على
التحقيقات التي قام بها الفريق المكلف
بحادثه العقيد الدلابيح وقادت بحصر
الاشتباه بمجموعه من الاشقاء من حمله
الفكر التكفيري قال الامن العام في بيان
ان القوه الامنيه الخاصه حاصرت مكان
المشتبه بهم اذ قام احدهم وفورا بدء
المداهمه باطلاق اعيره الناريه مكثفه ما
اسفر عن مقتل ثلاثه من ضباط وافراد القوه
واصابه خمسه اخرين ومقتل الارهابي مطلق
النار اضاف البيان ان المداهمه الى القاء
القبض على تسعه اخرين مشتبه بهم منهم
اربعه اشقاء للارهابي المقتول وثلاثه
اخرون من ابناء احدهم ومعهم شخصان اخران
كان برفقتهم وقد ضبط بحوزتهم مجموعه من
الاسلحه الناريه وكميه كبيره من الذخيره
صوت اكثر من 10 ملايين شخص نعم من اجل
تنحي مالك تويتر الجديده لهم ماسك عن
الرئاسه كان الملياردير الامريكي لهن ماسك
قد فاجا متابعيه بعدما اطلق استطلاعا
للراي حول تنحيهم من منصبه كرئيس لمنصه
تويتر شكلت نسبه المصوتين بنعم 57.5 من
اجمالي المصوتين والذين تجاوز عددهم 17
مليون و500,000 شخص شاركوا في الاستفتاء
الذي استمر لا 24 ساعه كان الون ماسك تعهد
بالالتزام بنتيجه التصويت مهما كانت
[موسيقى]
وهذه عوده مشاهدينا للبيان الذي اصدره
الامن العام الاردني والذي اكد ان قوه
امنيه خاصه نفذت مداهمه لخليه ارهابيه في
منطقه الحسينيه في معان على كل المزيد حول
تفكيك هذه الخليه الارهابيه معنى من
محافظه معان مراسل العربيه عماد العضايله
اهلا بك عماد بدايه الجديد حول هذه
العمليه
ميسون لا جديد يعني الاوضاع هنا في منطقه
الحسينيه وفي محافظه معان الاوضاع هادئه
جدا هناك تواجد امني في هذه المنطقه تجوز
السيارات الامن العام ومركبات الامن العام
تجوب بين الحين والاخر في هذا الشارع
الرئيسي همم الاوضاع كما تحدثنا هادئه يوم
امس كان هناك مداهمه هذه المداهمه اسفرت
عن مقتل همم مقتل ثلاثه من ضباط الامن
العام واصابه خمسه اخرين المداهمه كانت
بعد الوصول لبعض التفاصيل او ال- حول
المجتمع به خاصه ان هذه المنطقه هي كانت
يعني على مدار يومين كانت تمشط من قبل
الاجهزه الامنيه لمعرفه ولي اخذ بعض همم
يعني همم التفاصيل او بعض ما تخلفه همم
المجتبه به في قتل الضابط الاردني الذبح
هذا التحول الذي وصلنا اليه اليوم من همم
يعني تفكيك هذه الخليه ان انجاز التعبير
همم بعد مقتل الضابط الدلابيح في هذه
المنطقه في هذا المكان تحديدا قتل من هذه
المنطقه تم اطلاق النار عليه بهذا الاتجاه
ومن ثم قامت الاجهزه الامنيه همم يعني همم
التحري والوصول للمجتمع به واا قامت
بمداهمته يوم امس في هذه المنطقه طبعا ال-
ال- يعني ال- ال- ال-
الاجهزه الامنيه دائما لها همم يعني همم
دائما لديه تجارب يعني بشكل عام الاردن
لديه تجارب سابقه وكثيره مع التعامل مع
ال- ال- اصحاب الفكر المتطرف وخاض ايضا
وخاض ايضا معارك ضد هذا دائما وعاده همم
يتم همم مداهمه منازل ومداهمه اوكار
للمتطرفين همم اليوم وبعد الكشف عن هذه
المعلومات
العربيه عماد الاعضاء اللي شكرا جزيلا لك
لانني سانتقل مباشره الى زياره الرئيس
الروسي وهذه الكلمه من بيلاروسيا منسك
في مجال الطاقه
النوويه ولقد بدا عمل
المفاعل الاول الذي يعوضون اكثر من اربع
فصل خمسه مليار متر مكعب من الغاز الطبيعي
هذه المحطه الكهربائيه تعمل وتولد الطاقه
الكهربائيه التي توافق وتعادل اربعه فاصله
خمسه مليار متر مكعب من الغاز الطبيعي
هذا المشروع لبناء مفعلات جديده والامر
الاهم هو ان ان
نستعدون
اللي همم
وهذا القطعه من الاقتصاد وتاهيل الكادر
الوطنيين ولدينا اتفاقيات بهذا الخصوص
ومستعدون لمواصله لمناقشه هذه القضايا
والمضيق قدما لتطبيق وتنفيذ برامجنا في
هذا المجال ولدينا ايضا مسرات اخرى مثيره
للاهتمام
تتعلق بالمسار المالي بما في ذلك في اطار
الاتحاد الاقتصادي لقراسي وايضا هناك مسار
متعلق بالتعاون العسكري التقني ولا يرتبط
فقط بتوريدات متبادله من الاسلحه والمعدات
ايضا العمل
والتكامل في مجال
تطوير التقنيات العاليه
هو كل هذه المنجزات
اهتم بها
واعتقد انه علينا اليوم نقوم باستخراج
الاستخلاص الاستنتاجات لما قد انجزناه
ونرسم خطط جديده للمستقبل
وفيما يتعلق بالتعاون في مجال الفضاء
فلذين ايضا خطه مرتبطه بهذا الامر
[موسيقى]
نكتفي بهذا القدر من هذه الكلمه للرئيس
الروسي فيلاديمير بوتين طبعا المتواجد في
زياره هي الاولى له منذ ثلاث سنوات الى
بلاروسيا وطبعا
تتزامن هذه الزياره مع اييي طبعا مناورات
تقام تكتيكيه كما يقال بين الجانبين
البيلاروسيا والروسي وفيكم بالمزيد من
التفاصيل حاله ورودها ولكن اسمحوا لي ان
اعود الى الخبر الذي ذكرناه فيما يتعلق
بالون ماسك واستطلاع الراي والاستفتاء
الذي
دفعه همم او مال اكتر الى ان يستقيل من
منصبه كرئيس لتويتر طبعا معنا من جده عادل
الغامدي الباحث في تقنيه وامن المعلومات
اهلا بك سيد عادل طبعا ليس الاستفتاء
الاول كان في استطلاع قبل كم يوم فيما
يتعلق بتعليق صفحات همم
الصحفيين على تويتر
كانت هناك همم الدعم كان هناك نوع من
الدعم من قبل المتابعين كي تعود بعض
الصفحات وعادت هل هذا يعطينا فكره عن كيف
يفكر الان ماسك وكيف سيتعامل مع هذه
النتيجه
غير متوقع عمله في وقت غير متوقع الناس
مشغولين مع كاس العالم عام 1924 ساعه همم
المستطيل تقريبا 12 مليون صوت 57% طلبوا
منه التنحيف همم شخص غير اعتيادي بيحط
طلبات بيحط تقريبا
[موسيقى]
السابق نفذ ما طلبه او ما ملا اليه العدل
الاكبر من المتابعين وبالتالي سؤالي ان
كان همم يفعل نفس الشيء حتى في هذا
الاستفتاء او لا انت تشكك
انا انا ما انا لا اتوقع انه خائف على
الشيء هذا همم التصويت كم مده يوم واحد
اييي تويتر في تقريبا 200 مليون مستخدم
فانت لما تعمل تصويت تحط فتره يوم واحد
وفي نفس الفتره هذه الناس مشغوله مع كاس
العالم
لا حتى التصوير هيكون غير عادي يعني عاطل
تصوير ثلاثه اربعه ايام اسبوع المده
الاقصى تويتر فقط 24 ساعه وعادل اللي
يصوتوا 12 مليون ما يوصلون 10% من
المستخدمين تويتر فما اعتقد انه عندهم
الصلاحيه
باستغلال او تعرف
تويتر ام لا ما عندهم الصلاحيه ولكن هل
تعطينا فكره عن مزاج المتابع على تويتر او
اعضاء تويتر اذا ما صح التعبير المغردين
ورفضهم همم حتى الناس
لهم ماسكه داخل بعنف بصراحه داخل يتحدث
داخل يكسر كل القوانين اااه داخل في
الصراعات داخل في الصراع مع ابل وقال انه
ما عنده مشكله ورفض انه يعطي لهم المبالغ
قبل حدث ان تحذف البرنامج في النهايه
خضراء للتهديدات ورفع للساعه علامه زرقاء
رفع رسوم السا الشهريه حقهم همم
ماشي بطريقه حتى تواجد في كاس العالم يوم
امس الناس كلها كانت تنتقد تصرفاته تنتقل
دخوله همم الموقع بهذا الحجم اللي حدث
عالمي وهو داخله بسيط جدا همم يتعكس بساطه
تعكس عقليه الشخص انه ما هو مهتم همم ايش
اللي بيعمله بالضبط بصراحه له الماس زي ما
احنا شايفين اخر تقريبا شهر او اخر شهر
ونصف كل يومين ثلاثه في تحديات في
الصراعات همم وقف حساب الشخص اللي كان قال
حريه التعبير في شخص كان يتبع همم الطياره
الخاصه بالهن ماستر بينزل اخبار اول باول
وقف حسابه قالوا لا حريه التعبير لا هذا
التبع فهي مشكله القوانين التواصل
الاجتماعي لنا قوانين الطاقه
سيتفاعل مع هذه النتيجه من جده عادل
الغامدي الباحث في تقنيه وامن المعلومات
شكرا جزيلا لك
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
الاتحاد الاوروبي يتهموا شركه ماتا بخرق
قواعد مكافحه الاحتكار
مشاهدين اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه ونقل
لكم هذه الصور التي يتم تداولها للمنزل
الذي تمت مداهمته من قبل القوات الاردنيه
تم تفكيك خليه ارهابيه متهمه بالضلوع في
مقتل الدلابيح وطبعا مداهمه ادت الى مقتل
ثلاثه من ضباط وافراد القوه اصابه ايضا
خمسه اخرين ومقتل الارهاب الذي اطلق النار
حول بدات
المداهمه طبعا كان هناك بيان للامن العام
الاردني تحدث فيه ايضا عن القاء القبض على
تسعه اخرين مشتبه بهم ايه تحدث عن اربعه
اشقاء للارهاب المقتول وثلاثه اخرين من
ابناء احدهم وايضا تحدث عن شخصين اخرين
كان نبي رفقه هؤلاء
والقوى الامنيه والامن العام الاردني تحدث
عن انه ضبط بحوزتهم مجموعه من الاسلحه
الناريه
نيه كبيره من الذخيره ونشاهد من خلال هذه
الصور طلقات النار على الحيطان والتي تدل
على حجب المواجهه بين الجانبين
الى ايران الان دخل المحتجون الايرانيون
في اضرابهم ولمده ثلاثه ايام تمديدا بقمع
قوات الامن وبسياسه الاعدامات التي يتبعها
النظام ردا على الاحتجاجات شهدت عده مناطق
بالعاصمه وطهران احتجاجات ضد النظام شملت
احياء منها ستار خان وشاهين الجنوبيه
وسعاده اباد ردد المتظاهرون الايرانيون
عبارات مناهضه للنظام وللمرشد الايرانيه
صالون ايجاد رايك
[موسيقى]
مع تصاعد الاحتجاجات في انحاء ايران ومات
لها من حمله قمع نفذتها قوات الامن باتت
الحكومه تركز كثيرا على اغلاق المواقع
وايضا الصفحات المناهضه للسلطات على
الانترنت ومواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ولكن
في الكواليس يشعر البعض بالقلق من ان
الحكومه تستخدم التكنولوجيا بطريقه اخرى
وتتمثل في قرصنه واختراق تطبيقات الهاتف
الجوال لمراقبه وقمع المعارضه كشفت احدى
المحتجزات في سجن ايفين الشهير بشمال
طهران كشفت لشبكه سي ان ان الامريكيه ان
السلطات اخترقت حساباتها على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي فتشت في المحادثات
والرسائل النصيه الخاصه بها لتوريتها في
جرائم بعينها طبعا بحسب سي ان فقط هددت
السلطات الفتاه المحتجزه اثناء استجوابها
بان مصيرها سيكون الاعدام حيث تواجه
التهامات باداره بمجموعه ناشطه مناهضه
للنظام على تطبيق تيليجرام وهو طبعا ادعاء
فيه الفتاه تعتقد الفتاه الايرانيه ان
عملاء ايرانيين اخترقوا حساب تيليجرام
الخاص بها في يوليو الماضي اثناء وجودها
في السجن على حد قولها حيث اعاده السلطات
تنشيطه حسابها على التطبيق لمعرفه من حاول
الاتصال بها والكشف عن النشطاء السياسيين
الذين كانت على تواصل معهم يحذر نشطاء
حقوق الانسان من قدره النظام الايراني على
اختراقه هواتف المتظاهرين والمعارضين
والوصول الى الصور والبيانات وسجلات
والمكالمات وغيرها من المعلومات الشخصيه
الهامه وذلك عن بعد
[تصفيق]
هذا هو من جهه اخرى
ليوم طهران بعد يوم من وصوله لاجراء
محادثات مع رئيس منظمه الطاقه الذريه
صحيفه ايران ديلي ذكرت ان الوفد اجرى
مباحثات وصفتها بالمكثفه مع مسؤولين منظمه
الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه ومسؤولينا من
وزاره الخارجيه وفي وقت سابق اليوم قال
وزير الخارجيه حسين امير عبد الاهيان ان
بلاده مستعد للعوده الى التزاماتها في ما
يخص الاتفاق النووي مضيفا انه اذا ما عاده
الولايات المتحده للاتفاق النووي فانا
ايران مستعده للعوده الى جميع التزاماتها
بموجب اتفاق
باب للدبلوماسيه لا يزال مفتوحا على
مصراعيه امام التفاوض بشان احياء الاتفاق
النووي الايراني لعام 2015
وفق تقرير لرويترز
منذ عامين تقريبا حاولت الاداره الامريكيه
رغم التعنت الايراني كما ذكر دبلوماسيون
في واشنطن وفشلت في احياء الاتفاق لكن
الولايات المتحده حلفاءها الاوروبيين
يرفضون قطع الامل
التفاؤل الغربي بشان الاتفاق يعكس خطوره
المقاربات البديله كما نواها دبلوماسيون
غربيون تحدثت اليهم رايترز المسؤولون في
العواصم الغربيه يشددون على انهم لا
يعتقدون ان هناك اي خطه للقيام بعمل عسكري
ضد ايران لان الضربه قد تعزز ببساطه اي
رغبه ايرانيه في الحصول على اسلحه النوويه
وتخاطر برد ايراني
ايران الان تقوم بتخصيب اليورانيوم وصولا
لنسبه 60 في محطتها النوويه فوردو متجاوزه
الى حد كبير عتبه الثلاثه في المئه فاصل
67 المحدده بموجب الاتفاق النووي لكن لا
تزال بعيده عن عتبه التسعين بالمائه
اللازمه لصنع قنبله ذريه وهو ما قال
دبلوماسيون انهم يعتبرونه خطا احمر حسب
رويترز
مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه بالاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيف بوريل راى اخيرا الا خيار افضل من
خطه العمل الشامله المشتركه لضمان عدم
تطوير ايران لاسلحه النوويه حبل العقوبات
بات يخنق ايران ونظامها القمعي وابقى
تعبير دبلوماسيين غربيين
احتجاجات داخليه وعزه دوليه لكن المرجح في
المرحله الحاليه وفق تقرير رويترز ان هذا
لن يمنع ابقاء الدبلوماسيه حيه حتى اذا
ماتت خطه العمل الشامله المشتركه المتصله
بالاتفاق النووي لعام 2015
قال حكموا مدينه كيف اولكسي كوليبا قال
انه هجوم روسيا بطائرات مسيره تسبب في
اضرار جسيمه وان ثلاث مناطق فيها دون
كهرباء الان وقت شنت روسيا هجمات باستخدام
35 طائره مسيره انتحاريه ايرانيه الصنع
على اوكرانيا استهدفت بنا تحتيه حيويه
وحولها في ثالث ضربه جويه
[موسيقى]
على كل الناس للمزيد ينضم الينا عبر سكايب
مناكير الصحه في محمد البابا اهلا بك محمد
اخر التطورات الميدانيه
حصلت على 250 مسيره من ايران خلال
الاسبوعين الماضي
القوات الروسيه خلال الفتره الماضيه
باستخدام المسايرات الايرانيه لقصف بعض
المدن الاوكرانيه وخاصه الضربات التي حصلت
صباح هذا اليوم عند الرابعه صباحا هاشمت
اكثر من 30 مشيره اوكرانيه العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف واستطاع الضرب يعني محطات
طاقه في وسط العاصمه الاوكرانيه في صالون
كدهون»
جدا وهذه المره الاولى التي نعاني يعني
بهذا الشكل في شبكه الاتصالات
والطاقه الكهربائيه لانه زينسكي كانا قد
تحدث بفرح بانه عاده الكهرباء على حوالي 6
مليون ايه من الاوكرانيين هل المناطق التي
نتحدث عنها مرتبطه بتلك المناطق ام انه تم
همم ضرب مناطق اخرى جديده
التيار الكهربائي بدات تعود ولكن جاءت
ضربه اليوم
وحرمت اجزاء كبيره من العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كييفا فقط العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف من
التيار الكهربائي جزء كبير الجهه الشماليه
والجنوبيه والغربيه من العصر الاوكرانيه
كيف تعاني تقنين شديد انا في هذه المنطقه
التي انا فيها منذ الثانيه عشر من مساء
الامس لم تزود هذه المنطقه في التيار
الكهربائي اكثر من 16 ساعه ولكن يعني همم
يعني عمرك والحاكم العسكري
قال ان فرق السياره تعمل لمعالجه وترميل
جميع الضربات التي او جميع الاعضاء التي
حصلت الفتره الماضيه
ايضا بالاتصال وايضا الانترنت
نعم نعم الى المنطقه التي نحن انا اعيش
فيها نعاني انقطاع شديد يعني انخفاض كثير
خطير لشبكه الانترنت وشبكه الاتصالات
الصحفي محمد البابا شكرا جزيلا لك
وصل الرئيس
في اول زياره منذ ثلاث سنوات جاء ذلك في
الوقت الذي قالت فيه كيف انها تخشى هجوما
محتملا من الاراضي البيلاروسيا وقد بث
التلفزيون الروسي الرسمي مشاهد تظهر قوته
وهو ينزل من الطائره قبل ان يستقبله
لوكاشنكو بحراره مع مسؤولينا اخرنا على
مدرج المطار من جانبه قال المتحدث باسم
الكرم ان الرئيس الروسيس يبحث عن نظيره
البيلاروسيه علاقات الشراكه الاستراتيجيه
بين البلدين مستقبل دوله الاتحاد ايضا
وسيركزاني ايضا على القضايا الامنيه
والاجراءات المشتركه لمواجهه التحديات
الراهنه
وكنا قد سمعنا مشاهدينا الى جزء من كلمه
الرئيس الروسي من بلا روسيا والتي اكد
فيها عن قضيه التعاطي مع الملفات الرئيسيه
منها الطاقه النوويه وايضا تحدث عن الدعم
المالي وايضا الشراكه التي ذكر بانها يجب
ان تكون متكامله في ما يتعلق بالتكنولوجيا
والتقنيات العليا العسكريا طبعا ااه وكاله
انتركس كانت قد ذكرت ان القوات الروسيه
المتميزه في بيلاروسيا ستجرى منورات ايضا
تكتيكيه هذا اليوم ودون ان تحدد الوكاله
الوقت المحدد لاجراء تلك المناورات كانت
وزاره الدفاع البرسيه قالت في وقت سابق ان
تسعه الاف جندي روسي تحركوا الى بلا روسيا
من اجل حمايه حدودها
المزيد معنا عبر سكايب مناكير فولادمير
شوماكو بادبلوماسي السابق اهلا بك سيد
ديفولو دي مارس معنا الى جزء من كلمه
الرئيس الروسي لا اعلم ان كان بالامكان
اعطاءنا اهم ما خرج من هذه الكلمه و و
الرسائل من وراء هذه الزياره في هذا
التوقيت بالذات
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته مست
بتبقى في حاله تاهيل في حاله هجوم همم
روسيا بيضاء وروسيا من اراضي روسيا
فقط للتوضيح هذه الزياره بالنسبه لكم او
اللي همم العقليه الاوكرانيه تؤكد المخاوف
من انه هجوم قادم الان لا محاله من
بيلاروسيا وماذا يعني دخول بيلاروسيا على
الخط مباشره اذا نصح ذلك
لروسيا في حرب اوكرانيا من المعروف
في مستشفى مستشفيات الروسيه بيضاء ولكن هو
في الضوء فقط الروسيه في منطقه
يحتاج اي مساعده حتى
من الام ممكن سوف يكون هجوما او في نهايه
شهر يناير او في الشهر
[موسيقى]
اوكرانيا صعبه
او مش صعبه انا سؤالي يتعلق بدخول بلا
روسيا بشكل مباشر في هذه الحرب الاوكرانيه
ماذا يعني ان كان بالنسبه اوكرانيا او حتى
للحلفاء
شخصيا بصراحه بيان السيد همم لوكيشن كرئيس
بلروس هو الصوفي ينضم وفي هذه عمليه
وروسيا بيضاء هي سوف تهاجمه مع عروس
اوكرانيا من الممكن يكون
لانكرانيا سوف تحصل زياده من المساعده
همم سوف نرى في اقرب تقريبا بعد شهر شهرين
ولكن اكيد الجيش
هذا هجوم سوف يكون صعب جدا
وهو يركز على
جبهتين في جنوب بكره يعني
سوف تكون الجبهه جديده في شمال وفي شمال
غربي
الدبلوماسي السابق شكرا جزيلا لك
حضرت المفوضيه الاوروبيه شركه ماتا ملكه
تطبيق فيسبوك بسبب انتهاكها لقوانين
الاتحاد الاوروبي لمكافحه الاحتكار من
خلال تشويه المنافسه في اسواق الاعلانات
المبوبه عبر الانترنت واساءه استخدام
مكانتها السوقيه المفوضيه قالت انها سوف
تحقق في الامر وانه يمكن ان تفرض غرامه
تصل الى 10% من حجم المبيعات العالم
السنوي للشركه اذا كان هناك ادله كافيه
على انتهاك قواعد الاتحاد الاوروبي
في هذه النشره ولكن بعد قليل
الاتحاد الاوروبي يدرس مقترحا بتخفيض سقف
اسعار الغاز والمانيا ابرز المعتقد
الرياضيا
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه يجتمعوا وزراء
الطاقه في دول الاتحاد الاوروبي في بروكسل
اليوم في محاوله للاتفاق على حد اقصى
لاسعار الغاز في احدث خطوه للتغلب على
ازمه الطاقه في اوروبا والناجمه عن الحرب
في اوكرانيا ورغم الشهور من المفاوضات
وعقد اجتماعين وزاريين طاريين حول مقترح
الاتحاد الاوروبي لوضع سقف للسعر لم
تتواصل الدول لاتفاقا بشانه كما انها
تختلف في ما بينها حول مائده كان يمكن ان
يخفف من ازمه الطاقه في اوروبا او سوف
يقيمها ومنذ انقطعت موسكو غالبيه الغاز
الذي كانت ترسله الى اوروبا توجه الدول
الاوروبيه ارتفاعا غير مسبوق في الاسعار
ما دفع التضخم الى مستويات قياسيه بناء
عليه وضعت تشيك التي تتولى الرئاسه
الدوريه للاتحاد الاوروبي مسوده اتفاق
جديد في محاوله لكسر الجنود الحالي وتؤكد
الدول المؤيده لفرد سقف لاسعار الغاز ان
الحد الاقصى بان يكون دون ال 200 يورو لكل
ميغاوات في الساعه حتى يفلح في التعامل مع
ارتفاع اسعار الغاز الذي تسبب في ارتفاع
فواتير المستهلكين وكاله بلومبرج لافتات
الى ان خطه التدخل في السوق التي كشفت
عنها المفوضيه الاوروبيه الشهر الماضي
تسببت في خلافات عميقه بين الاعضاء موضحه
ان بعض الدول على راسها المانيا وهولندا
والدنمارك تدعو الى نهج حذر بينما تضغط
مجموعه اخرى تضم بلجيكا وايطاليا واليونان
وبولندا لاستخدام ادوات اكثر فعاليه
للسيطره على اسعار الغاز يشكك بعض
الدبلوماسيين في امكانيه التوصل الى اتفاق
هذا الاسبوع 10 الى ان الدول غير الراضيه
عن الاقتراح الاحدث لديها ما يكفي من
الدعم لمنع الموافقه عليه
[موسيقى]
من جانبها قالت مفاوضات الطاقه الاوروبيه
كادر سامسونج
المزيد ينضم الينا من باريس الدكتور حسان
القبه الباحث في الاقتصاد السياسي اهلا بك
دكتور حسان دعني ابدا
بالمشكل الرئيس في عدم التوصل الى اتفاق
حول تحديد سقف لاسعار الغاز اين تكمن
المشكله من تطبيقه لعدم التطبيقه ما بين
الدول
كل فريق العربيه وعموم المشاهدين نعم هناك
تباين كبير بين شركاء الاوروبيين كتباين
الخرط الجغرافيه للقاره الاوروبيه او
للاتحاد الاوروبي لان يعرف الجميع ان
العديد من الدول لديها البنيه التحتيه
اليوم لاستقبال الغاز المسيء والتعويض على
الغاز الروسي بينما دول اخرى ما زالت
مرتبطه ارتباطا وثيقا بالغاز الروسي بحكم
همم بنيه التحتيه واستحاله استقبال الغاز
المسيئه حتى دوله مثل الالمانيه ممكن
البحر في البحر الاسبوع المنصرم تمكن من
احداث واحد عائمه لاستقبل الغاز المثال
ولكن حتى الان البنيه التحتيه الاوروبيه
غير متجانسه بالمره هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه
اخرى كذلك التباين التباين في مدى قياس
ارتداد هذا القرار هناك من يرى ان هذا
القرار قد يخفف ازمه الطاقه على الاوروبيه
ولكن العديد منهم المانيا والمانيا تتخوف
على اقتصاد الالماني بالاساس ان تكون
الارتدادت العكسيه لان متجربه ومنذ بدايه
العقوبات التي بدات تصدر حتى قبل العمليه
العسكريه منذ 22 فبراير الماضي همم
الارتدادات العقوبات الاوروبيه جاءت عكسيه
كثيره من اقتصاد الاوروبي
رؤيه الدول ماذا عنك كمراقب اقتصادي الى
ماذا تميل وبالمقابل عندما يتم الحديث عن
تقديم تنازلات طبيعه التنازلات التي يمكن
ان تقدم
نعم بالنسبه ابدا بالجزء الثاني من السؤال
التنازلات اعتقد ان هناك دول لا يمكن ان
تتنازل بحكم كما قلت البنيه التحتيه وبحكم
كذلك يعني تكاليف او كلفه الغاز الروسي
الذي يعتبر باثار تفاضليه اذا من الناحيه
الاولى على راسهم ربما المجال كذلك
المانيا هولندا بالنسبه لنظره الشخصيه
حقيقه سيده الكريمه ونحن ندرس الاقتصاد
منذ سنوات في فرنسا ممكن من اهم الدروس
التي نقدمها لطلبه الثانويه الاولى ان
السعر لا يحدده الا قانون العرض والطلب ان
كانوا يريدون ممكن اسعار اقل عليهم
التفكير في الاستثمار اكثر في البنيه
التحتيه الغازيه لتوفير معروض اكثر لان كل
ما ارتفع الغاز المعروضه على الاسواق
العالميه كلما يعني نزل سعره ولكن سرقه
السياسيه
نعم بطبيعه الحاله الاستثمارات في على
البنيه التحتيه الغازيه تحدث سنوات وتحتاج
ممكن حتى اكثر راس مال اكثر للذهاب
للاستثمار في هذه المشاريع لتوفير معروف
اكثر
السعر سيدتي الكريمه لا يحدده الا قانون
العرض والطلب هذا دون الحديث ربما لو
اتسعنا الوقت الى الموقف الروسي لان كذلك
الموقف الروسي مهم وراء اين عندما قرر
بوتن الدفعه بالروبل في مارس اذار نهايه
مارس اذار واعطى مهله شهر مع نهايه مايو
دخل في التنفيذ لا اعتقد ان الروس ليوم
سوف يقبلون باي قانون يحدد سقف السعر واي
دوله سوف تتبنى هذا القانون سوف يقطع
عليها الغاز الروسي علما ان التقارير
المنظمه الدوليه على راسهم منظمه التنميه
همم منظمه التعاون الاقتصادي والتنميه
تقول ان مع نهايه شهر
المخازين الاستراتيجيه سوف تكون في المئه
ومنه سوف يدخل اوروبا من جديد الاوروبيين
من جديد في تسابق مع الزمن لمل الزنات لسه
القادمه
ماذا تتوقع الان اتفاق لا اتفاق او انه ان
يجد حلول في حلول اخرى موجوده او لا
اتفاق وان حصل اتفاق يجب التفكير في صندوق
تعويضات للدول الاكثر تضررا ولكن في تقدير
الشخصي لا اتفاق وان حصلت اتفاق اكيد
سيكون بتعويضات كبيره لان كلفه كلفه
الطاقه لهذه السنه سيده الكريمه الفاتوره
الاوروبيه تجاوزت التريليون دولار حتى هذه
اللحظه
الدكتور حسان القبه السياسي شكرا جزيلا لك
على هذه المعلومات
بشارع القصر بالخرطوم كانت تنسيقات لجان
مقاومه ولايه الخرطوم اعلنت عن تظاهرات
اليوم تحت عنوان ارادته شعب وحددت القصر
الجمهوري كوجهها نهائيا تتزامن التظاهرات
مع حلول الذكر الرابعه للثوره التي اندلعت
في التاسعه عشر من ديسمبر 2018
اعلنت الهيئه العليا المستقله للانتخابات
في تونس ان النتائج الاوليه للانتخابات
التشريعيه تظهر فوزا واحدا و20 مرشحا من
الدور الاول للانتخابات وكاله تونس
افريقيا للانباء نقلت عن الناطق باسم
الهيئه العليا المستقله للانتخابات محمد
التليلي قوله ان المعطيات الاوليه
المتعلقه بفرز نتائج الانتخابات التشريعيه
تظهر فوزه 21 مرشحا من الدور الاول والدور
الثاني سيشمل مئه
وثلاثه وثلاثين دائره من جمله
161 دائره كما اعلنت عن الغاء ان الجزئي
وكلي لنتائج في بعض الدوائر الانتخابيه
بسبب تسجيل خروجات
رفضت المحكمه العليا السويديه قرار ترحيل
الصحه في التركي بولندا الذي تطالب به
تركيا من اجل اعطاء الضوء الاخضر
دون ارسال الصحفي وهو رئيس التحرير السابق
لصحيفه زمان التركيه والذي تتهمه انقره
بالطورط في محاوله الانقلاب عام 2016
اشاره المحكمه الى ان كنيسه اذا عاد الى
تركيا فانه معرض لخطر الاضطهاد بسبب
قناعاته السياسيه
الدنيا الاصليه للكائن الفضائي الذي
يتمحورت حوله قصه فيلم ايتي الشهير للمخرج
ستيفن سبيل برج نهايه الاسبوع الماضي
مقابل اثنين فاصله سته مليون دولار وفقا
منظمي المزاد
[موسيقى]
اي تي جو هون طبعا معظم الزملاء بالقلري
مش حاضرينه انا من الحاضرين شكرا لمتابعه
مشاهدينا
ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]